i'm glad to be virtually connected now
to the jury chair of the winner's
session in the category science
engagement and talk to her
hello melanie smallman co-director of
the new center for science communication
at ucl
hello nice having you with us hi
how do you regard the role of science
engagement today
yeah i think that involving people
in thinking about and doing science has
always been really really important
but i think this year we've seen you
know in the face of a global pandemic
that getting it right for some people
can be
a matter of life or death so i think you
know whether
you're you're involving citizens in
helping them understand how vaccines
work
or just encouraging more young people to
go into science i think it's really
vital work right now
yeah we are looking forward very much to
see the breakthroughs of the year in in
this
category today and it seems there is a
lot of creativity
in it a lot of enthusiasm can you give
us a sneak peek into the category
yeah we saw an amazing array of projects
that are involving citizens in science
and discussions about science
from across the world every corner of
the world was represented
we even had projects that were going
into prisons to involve
people in thinking about science and we
saw
projects that were helping women
and girls into science we saw projects
that were bringing communities together
through astronomy we even saw projects
that were
trapping people in science-themed escape
rooms so that they could learn more
about science
and the things they had in common was
that they were original
like you say that their their owners
were enthusiastic
um but most importantly they were really
sort of breaking down that wall between
science and society
you obviously have a great overview over
the subjects and over the projects we
will
see um what are your practical
recommendations to scientists who want
to engage the public
well i think there's two really
important things
um for scientists wanting to engage with
the public to do
so first of all think really hard about
your audience think about who it is you
want to
engage why they may be interested in
science
um but also think about what you could
learn from them so that it's listening
as well as speaking
and i think secondly there's loads of
projects
engaging citizens with science so look
around and see if somebody is already
doing or has tried what you're
interested in
and because you might learn something
from them they may have lessons for you
and a really good place to start are the
engaged projects that we're showcasing
today
melanie can you tell us how does the
pandemic
change the way scientists are
communicating their issues
yeah well i think it's become suddenly
all the more important
that people hear from the scientists
about um the science and have you know a
better understanding of how diseases and
vaccines work
and i think one of the things that we
have seen is scientists becoming much
more visible
so a lot more pressure on them to
communicate and a lot more need
to learn from the past about how to do
it better so we've had a case
a situation um in the past few weeks
where
the scientists used lots of graphs in a
press conference and loads of people
you know found these really difficult to
understand so communicating effectively
um is really really important but the
encouraging thing
is that all of the surveys around the
world
have shown that public confidence and
public trust in scientists
has really gone up during the pandemic
as scientists have come out
and communicated the public have
responded very positively to
it okay thank you for the moment melanie
you stay with us since you will join the
winner sessions
you will be the jury chair for the
category
science engagement so thank you for the
moment